yeah this guy looks like he's he's going
he looks like the accomplished I kind of
didn't know what he was doing and it's
kind of like they both look like they're
up to no good they both look like
Zachary Quinto bro yeah yeah yeah bro
he's gonna kill me and they already have
a face of failure so just throw him in
jail for Life yeah I agree we had their
back so hard or at least send them back
to Planet Vulcan
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right so there's two Texas high
school students that are facing up to 10
years in prison for their school prank
what do you think could be that 10 years
whoa 10 years what could be so bad of a
school prank that it could get you a
decade was there any deaths involved no
deaths okay was it like a fake bomb or
something or like did they did they maim
a janitor no I can't answer because I
looked at it
give us a good guess is it like one of
those old school pranks that they
brought back like stealing a car and
putting it on a on the roof of a of a
school that's pretty sweet here we'll
have since Ron knows what it is we'll
have you demonstrate with in silent
movements
as if you're reacting to the thing that
happened
oh my reaction you're a person as a
victim of this prank
that's poop that's poop that's poop
related oh they played Taylor Swift on
the loudspeaker Taylor Swift Taylor
Swift that poop related that's poop
related they poured throw up on somebody
hey
blow some gas into the school oh yeah
they these two kids bought some fart
spray and they spread it in the school
and apparently the set was so bad that
they had to evacuate twice
and some students had to go to the
hospital for like nausea and 10 years
for this [__] yeah 10 years too much
that's in the book in the law like the
actual book of Law Of Texas it's 10
years for what they did because it's
considered uh an attack yeah it's like
considered like a gas attack versus a
biological warfare the judge is gonna
get this case and be like look oh it's
possession it's possession of a
prohibited weapon which is a third
degree felony whoa It's a bomb I usually
like Texas but this time Texas failed I
love Texas where's Bart think about this
it would have been fine if it was a gun
oh man I don't know
aren't suspended Bart's normal pool is
to let people [__] around
I do like letting people [__] around I
think 10 years is kind of rough dude
fart fart gas is who would have thought
I know who would have thought it was
amazing and it's a senior prank it's a
weird stipulation and no one really got
hurt it's just a smell did they check
the reviews did they know it's a
five-star fart bomb yeah yeah yeah like
or do they think we don't know it's
probably weak we have to buy a lot of it
the reviews on Amazon you can't tell
these days you don't know what kind of a
product you're getting you're like God
how about square footage like 50 000
square feet they base they miscalculated
guys it's just a math yeah ruined these
kids lives it's the school sport that
they couldn't calculate how much gas
they needed yeah yeah they were doing
the metric system
if they let them go to jail if they have
to follow the rules then maybe they
could send some hookers in with them
so they could at least lose their
virginity yeah they have fun and then
maybe give them some like more like gas
chemical experiment kits so they could
keep progressing
they can make a more potent spray they
can Master their crowd the spray that
they used was called hens gauk fart
spray uh so we're gonna test it
I actually thought about it but I
couldn't get this in time but there's no
way we would have to evacuate well it
sucks because never think some gigs ate
dick chips
I got my dad he's calling me be like hey
are you Nikki okay I'm like yeah he's
like oh eating [__] dick chips all
the time I guess
smelling her breath yeah it's like
butterscotch no I wouldn't do that but
yeah it's apparently that specific brand
of fart spray it's just that bad
apparently but okay like has anyone in
school ever done that because I feel
like that happened
not smell wise I don't think bombs I did
from the ice cream truck you remember
those yeah they're both don't last very
long though you go like that if it rains
the next day it's gone yeah and is it
just sulfur yeah I think so right I
don't know it's like the same [__] like
in cap guns okay I thought it was so
cool though when kids had it it was like
illegal Contraband really stunk that
[__] was tight that was good it was very
strong for the moment it didn't cause
this I just can't believe imagine going
to jail for 10 years I think it's a
weird stipulation the judges upon me
like look this is what you should be
you're gonna do community service yeah
because I think it's gonna ruin in their
lives because like you got these two
kids right they're in jail and they're
with some [__] 40 year old man and
he's like what are you in here for oh I
[__] like cut off someone's hand or
some [__] they're like what are you
saying
he doesn't remember my senior break I I
cut off a guy
I was like wouldn't that be funny if we
got one arm Tony yeah because I was I
was definitely thinking like for a crime
like this like what other crimes you get
sent in jail with like what's adjacent
to this because these kids
careers are ruined this clearly wasn't
L.A County bro you know what I do like I
like that there's a 10-year sentence to
hang over their heads to teach them a
lesson okay yeah that's true I don't
think I mean it's staring them a little
bit is a good thing it probably won't
happen like that's super unlike that's
like what North Korea was trying to do
with auto warmbeyer but then they just
it got out of hand and he just died
you're like we're just trying to scare
the show this kid and then like Ah
that's probably got out of hand you're
probably like I didn't know Americans
were so weak yeah yeah they're like wait
because Americans can't like [__] be
beat up for like 48 Hours like a week
he's all like North Koreans can
do three weeks of torture Americans
can't even do two it is a very
untextious thing though I feel like it's
I think so too I think something fair is
like make them uh repaint one of the
buildings or scrape gum off the sidewalk
community service she hates it make them
Watch Sailor Moon for like like [__]
three years every night you go home you
gotta Watch Sailor Moon dude that's not
torture that's that's kind of cool if
it's the
dub it might be
is that the black tuxedo
yeah so they were arrested they released
on Broad same day three thousand dollars
bond interest
of only three thousand dollar Bond yeah
I mean I don't think they're gonna jump
on uh something like this you got mug
shots I would 10 years
yeah I'm leaving the country I would too
I'm a [__] fight wrestler what the
yeah you're leaving the country off of
that for 10 years 10 years at 19 years
we're probably not going to get to 10
years there's no way Texas might give
you 15. Texas might execute you to save
money dude
well you didn't tell me they look like
that give them 20. they look so scary
dude [__] you want to give them better
we're sentences off their looks that's
probably what happened is this
representative of Texas youth dude what
the Mexican Texas yeah Mr Spock haircuts
everywhere
what the [__] is that about dude yeah
this guy looks like he's he's going he
looks like the accomplished I kind of
didn't know what he was doing and it's
kind of like they both look like they're
up to no good they both look like
Zachary Quinto bro yeah yeah yeah bro
he's gonna kill me and they already have
a face of failure so just throw them in
jail for Life yeah I agree we had their
back so hard or at least send them back
to play
[Laughter]
they belong
um what's up with that hairstyle looking
like medieval peasants hey bro that's a
that's a trend everywhere [__] ball
cut ass bro Joe get one of those dude I
guess we all gotta do it dude no no you
wanna if you went to school you want to
look like Mr Spock nobody does hey that
guy he looks like peso pluma dude these
are all these are all the dudes at like
takeovers too my mom would literally
take a grapefruit put it over my head
and then trace it with a a grapefruit
with a grapefruit and it was not trendy
at the time I was a grapefruit yeah it's
good for your hair and then it's also a
hat
[Laughter]
keeps your head warm
in my early use like 10 years oldish
years I got bowl haircuts right with
constantly like they called the skater
cup but it's just a bowl haircut yeah
but like [__] Trek fans they'd be
like no it's a saucer-cut saucer yeah
[__] why do you think the bowl coat was
so popular in the 90s it was the hot
thing I think it's an easy haircut to do
and kids just look cute in them it was a
great DIY from parent to child yeah
because my mom would cut my hair all the
time and I look like I just put on a
full-on hair helmet that's so true it
was also in media too like I remember
three ninjas
and and
Rocky I think Lloyd Christmas had a bowl
cut what kind of who who had the first
bowl cut who who set it off the Beatles
maybe oh yeah the first polka it was
probably like a like a Martin Luther bro
Martin Luther yeah it was a monk dude
Martin Luther dude yeah the [__]
mission's been 95 pieces guy oh yeah
yeah I'm [__] like the 1200s yeah
dude that yeah Friar tough brother yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's where it comes
from Friar Chuck was missing that little
top part that's a good haircut put the
bowl upside down on his head cut around
it so you're so 10 years you think 20
20. based off the way they look I didn't
know they look like that I think homie
on the left you let him go homie on the
right you got to keep an eye on that guy
Texas tell us what you think because
oddly enough on our demographic our
highest uh viewed uh area is Houston
Texas wow there's a lot of diversity
there very cool so tell us Texas how you
guys feel about this dude yeah I want to
go to Houston yeah let's do a Houston
trip guys let's go to Houston I want to
get some barbecue and crawfish I want
barbecue baby I was conceived in Dallas
Texas little fun fact that's a hot fun
fact
[Music]
foreign